[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
de la tnt sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité stockage
et vaccination mobilisation en région
dans des lieux sécurisés
les flacons de vaccin sont manipulés
avec une extrême précaution nous avons
pu y avoir accès nous nous rendons à
bordeaux avec télé 7 pour comprendre le
processus mémoire de nos régions plus de
cent mille pages provenant de la presse
quotidienne régionale du début du xxème
siècle vont être scannés c'est la
mémoire de nos régions qui est en voie
de conservation numérique
les équipes de 7 à limoges ont suivi ce
processus pour nous sapeurs-pompiers
dans cette période de voeux nous avons
parfois à faire aux pompiers qui
frappent à nos portes pour nous proposer
leur calendrier
une profession un engagement plébiscité
est aimé par les français nous irons à
la rencontre grâce à vis occitanie de
celles qui ont décidé de devenir
sapeur-pompier au service de nous tous
germinal
nous nous rendrons dans ce journal sur
le tournage de la mini série germinal
qui se tourne dans les hauts de france
est en pleine crise sanitaire vous le
verrez trente ans après le film de
claude berri avec gérard depardieu et
renault une superproduction avec deux
mille quatre cents figurants et plus de
700 costumes ou et otele est allé
visiter le set de ce tournage hors norme
des chiens de traîneaux découverte
enneigées des vosges avec des images
superbes tourné par vosges télévision
dans ce journal
elles ne viennent pas du grand nord mais
des vosges enneigé que nous visiterons
avec nos amis les chiens de traîneau du
fun vous le verrez mais aussi du
spectaculaire pour vos idées de vacances
en famille depuis la conférence de
presse du premier ministre nous en
savons un peu plus sur ce qui sera notre
nouvelle vie dans les semaines qui
viennent
avec ce couvre-feu bien sûr à 18 heures
pour tous les départements de france
vaccination vaccin stockage ce sont des
sujets qui nous préoccupent tous
maintenant au coeur de toutes les
conversations des français
ces précieux petits flacons de vaccin
censé nous permettre d'être immunisés
ils sont gardés vous allez voir en lieu
sûr
exemple à bordeaux où les vaccins
destinés aux girondins sont manipulés
avec
grande précaution télé 7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest s'est rendu pour nous
sur un des lieux où ils seront stockés
bénédicte doha c'est ici que sont
stockés les flacons prêts à être envoyés
partout en gironde des flacons à
manipuler avec précaution chacun d'entre
eux contient cinq doses de vaccin un
vaccin à la conservation périlleuse la
durée de conservation et de trois
minutes à température ambiante
donc toute la difficulté ça va être de
préparer les flacons à destination bien
sûr des centres de vaccination installés
au chu de bordeaux mais aussi bien sûr
des établissements du département à
température
réfrigérer c'est à dire qu'il faut que
c'est là qu'on soit préparée entre 2 et
8 degrés conservés dans des congélateurs
à moins 80 degrés les flacons sont
systématiquement accompagnés du
dispositif médical nécessaire à la
vaccination des kits préparer un par un
par le personnel hospitalier mais c'est
de faire un double contrôle donc c'est
pour ça qu'on on est effectivement comme
sur une chaîne pour éviter toute erreur
toute traçabilité que tout soit bien
respecté donc j'ai une collègue qui
prépare eurocontrol
on en paquet et tout est contrôlé à
chaque fois à toute la chaîne du circuit
chaque jour jusqu'à quatre mille doses
de vaccin sont préparés à la
distribution une cadence élevée dont le
rythme n'est pas près de ralentir ça ne
va que cette série d'ea puisque on a
réellement
on a reçu les vaccins mardi on a démarré
mercredi donc
voyez on n'a même pas on n'est même pas
sur une semaine complète donc on sait
très bien que ça va ça va être costaud
le chu de bordeaux a reçu 1755 flacon un
stock visités par les députés girondine
et derangère couillard veronica merrer
et catherine fabre et puis regardez ces
images qui nous ont été envoyées par nos
partenaires de télé pas aisée et de
monaco info
des images de vaccination qui se
poursuivent sandrine est thomas
deus ont suivi le début de cette
vaccination du personnel soignant
monégasque très exposée depuis mars
dernier et encore vous le voyez aussi se
sont 1950 doses du vaccin teaser biotech
qui ont été livrées à bastia après une
matinée consacrée à la vaccination du
personnel médical les résidents
volontaires de l'ehpad de toga comme
vous le voyez sur ces images ont
bénéficié des vaccins dans l'après midi
la moitié de ces doses ensuite pris le
chemin de l'hôpital d'ajaccio
nous partons à présent dans la loire car
dans l'actualité il ya également les
traditionnels voeux de début d'année
pour chacun d'entre nous mais également
pour nos élus vous le savez à la roche
la molière le maire dans l'impossibilité
de présenter ses voeux dans une grande
assemblée comme ses pairs d'ailleurs à
décider des voeux d'un nouveau genre et
en musique
cécile r s'il y a de tl7 télé loire 7
l'accompagnait en swinguant pour la
playlist voyez avec le maire depuis
lundi mais aussi le soir du 31 décembre
eric berlivet endosse le rôle de dj
chauffeur animateur dans les rues de sa
commune
ne pouvons pas faire ses voeux comme
d'habitude dans chaque quartier de la
ville il a décidé cette année d'équipé
un camion de la ville pour annoncer la
bonne année aux balcons dans ses rôles
de mère oui faut le bien-être des
habitants les services ça en fait partie
donc certains trouvent ça un peu idiot
c'est pas grave moi je m'en fou le plus
important c'est que les gens soient
heureux c'est ça le truc on n'a qu'une
vie donc c'est déjà compliqué cette
pandémie
donc si on peut au moins donner un petit
peu de bonne humeur et voilà dans la
remorque ses adjoints élus choristes et
chorégraphe d'un soir
pas vraiment raccord avec les activités
habituelles âgées délégation commission
a donné très sérieux habituellement
pendant une petite halte quelques
rouchon rejoignent le camion pour
profiter de la musique et des petits
cadeaux distribués début comme ça on
n'en voit pas tous les jours
l'initiative est plutôt bien apprécié je
pensais être bonne idée
il a trouvé leur rapport au confinement
on peut pas trop sortir j'ai jamais vu
ça mais bon c'est pas mal c'est bien ça
change c'est original grâce à nîmes et
cela va durer comme ça encore toute
cette semaine de 17h à 19h le maire
d'arpenter la vingtaine de quartiers de
sa commune pour distribuer un peu de
joie à près de 10000 rouchon tout à fait
autre chose dans l'actualité la
bibliothèque multimédia de limoges
tout comme ses homologues de lille de
bordeaux de dijon ou encore de lyon va
numériser plus de cent mille pages
provenant de la presse quotidienne
régionale du 20e siècle
c'est toute la mémoire de nos régions
qui est ainsi on voit de conservation
numérique alain dru aux 2,7 à limoges a
suivi ce processus inédit passionnant
aussi qui servira aux générations
futures regarder
effervescence assumer et maîtrisée dans
les locaux de la bibliothèque le pôle
limousin et patrimoine prépare une
nouvelle campagne de numérisation de la
presse quotidienne avec la bibliothèque
nationale de france
cette fois ci ce sont cent mille pages
qui doivent être préparées vérifier voir
à réparer c'est tous les titres
régionaux
je sois le populaire du centre l'écho du
centre le petit limousin comme le
journal clash est en train de prendre en
ce moment ça peut être la gazette du
centre et c'est toute période avant la
numérisation il ya tout un processus de
sélection et de vérification des
origines aussi les pages abîmées on va
les restaurer
s'il ya des manques on va essayer de les
retrouver par ailleurs soit chez nos
collègues des archives départementales
soit chez nos collègues des archives
municipales ce qui est plus rare pour
les périodiques
alors on a des produits en fait qui sont
neutres
on va dire et on va juste en fait ça
ressemble un petit peu un morceau de
scotch
mais ça n'est pas vraiment ce n'est pas
du scotch effectivement c'est un produit
qui va coller qui va renforcer le
document et qui va permettre voilier de
prendre la page sans qu'elles se déchire
de nouveau
limoges engagé il ya plusieurs années la
numérisation des journaux locaux et
c'est la qualité du travail et la
réactivité des équipes qui ont séduit la
bnf départ est en revanche aussi compte
tenu de la qualité de conservation de
certains véhicules
on a été une scierie j'ai le soin de
remixer à l'utilisation de ces titres
soient reportés sur d'autres structures
toutes ses publications seront
progressivement consultables
gratuitement sur le site gallica.bnf.fr
et puis dans l'actualité le breakbeat et
les territoires depuis l'entrée en
vigueur de ce dernier nombre de choses
changent dans les relations entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
c'est le cas notamment du programme
erasmus ou les conditions d'études pour
les jeunes européens va être modifié tv
78 dans les yvelines à regarder pour
vous les chose d'encore plus près et si
vous êtes étudiant ce reportage va
vraiment vous intéressez regarder
alexandrine qu étudiante en journalisme
elle devrait être en angleterre en ce
moment kovy de 19 oblige le pays et
reconfirme et jusqu'à début mars et
depuis le 1er janvier
le royaume uni ne fait plus partie de
l'union européenne
le bric site est entrée en vigueur j'ai
commencé mes études avant décembre 2020
ça veut dire que j'ai juste à
m'appliquer à un truc qui s'appelle
lieux pierre salomez kim qui me permet
de rester à londres bien mes études et
de vivre et et de travailler à londres
où dont l'angleterre a mais les gens qui
commencent rond l'année prochaine en
septembre
ils n'auront pas le droit d'avoir un
prêt étudiant pour les études il on a
besoin d'un visa qui coûte environ 400
euros
du coup les écoles les masters pour vite
fait passer à 30 milles rôle est de 10
plus tard alexandrine souhaite
travailler au royaume uni une envie que
partage zoé étudiante en droit et
anglais pour elle qui devait partir en
erasmus en septembre ce sera peut-être
plus compliqué moi j'aimerais beaucoup
travailler en diplomatie
faire de la relation internationale et
j'aurais énormément travaillé énormément
aimé travailler en ambassade
après je pense que ce sera toujours
possible enfin j'espère en tout cas mais
je pense que c'est un fou chouia plus
compliqué parce que justement on n'a pas
tous ses accords avec l'union européenne
qui permet à tous les travailleurs de
bouger un petit peu n'importe où en
europe
outre l'aspect professionnel et
étudiants le break site impact aussi
leurs vies personnelles par exemple si
un proche souhaitent venir les voir en
angleterre
il faudra désormais un visa actuellement
150 mille européens étudiés au royaume
uni
dans cette période de voeux nous avons
parfois à faire aux pompiers qui
frappent à nos portes avec leur
calendrier souvent magnifiques
d'ailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs une profession
plébiscité est aimé par les français et
les françaises
c'est aussi pour cela que nous partons à
la rencontre de celles qui ont décidé de
devenir
et oui ça peut de pompière comme manon
quand audrey ou encore ma elles sont
seules à être aux commandes de la
caserne de lézignan-corbières et bien
c'est une journée très particulière pour
elle un reportage sur place dans l'aude
devient occitanie regarder audrée main
non encore maele elles ont toutes choisi
de devenir ce à peu ce pont pierre
professionnels aujourd'hui elles sont
une dizaine à être seul aux commandes de
la caserne de lézignan corbières
l'idée d'une journée 100% féminine est
né de leur capitaine c'est nécessaire a
démontré que l'activité de
sapeur-pompier volontaire ou le métier
de sapeur pompier professionnel est
accessible à tous et la meilleure façon
de le montrer c'était d'armé ne garde
complète à aujourd'hui sur le centre de
secours de lézignan avec une garde 100%
féminine
car plus qu'une journée entre femmes
c'est aussi un soulagement d'obtenir la
confiance de leurs supérieurs
si on est là c'est qu'on peut le faire
qu'on nous fait confiance et qu'on doute
pas de nos compétences et du fait qu'on
puisse passer une journée entre femmes
assurer les interventions qui peut y
avoir du quotidienne qui peut se passer
la journée départ pour un accident sur
l'autoroute une voiture a percuté une
sableuse des opérations toujours risqué
qui demandent de donner le meilleur de
soi même une exigence d'autant plus
importante selon ces femmes il faut être
à la hauteur des hommes voire plus pour
être valorisées en fait
il faut pas montrer de défaillance ou
quoi que ce soit une initiative qui
résonne comme un soulagement pour la
préfète de l'aude c'est quand même une
question démocratique de se dire qu'à un
moment donné la majorité de la
population est exclue
un certain nombre de métiers ou de
fonction au seul prétexte qu'elle a
qu'elle a t'elle creusot ou qu'elle n'a
pas tel chromosomes c'est quand même
assez surprenant
les pompiers de l'aude compte 30% des
effectifs féminins au niveau national ce
chiffre descend à 17 % plus léger mais
gustatif dans ce gîte et nous allons
nous rendre en corse maintenant c'est
l'année du bicentenaire de napoléon et
chacun à sa manière sur l'île de beauté
cherche le moyen le plus original de
célébrer cet événement dont confrères de
corse matin vous allez le voir ont
déniché une pâtisserie d'ajaccio qui a
décidé de le faire d'une manière pour le
moins très original
regardez
cette année pour le bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon donc au mois de mai
nous avons décidé de faire une
collection de fèves essentiellement sur
la famille de napoléon bonaparte
joséphine
mais nous avons aussi décidé de parler
de napoléon iii et de sa femme donc
génie parce qu'ils ont fait énormément
de bien pour ajaccio et ont trouvé que
c'était normal voilà d'une sphère cet
honneur tous les ans nous faisons un
thème différent mais toujours sur la
ville d'ajaccio sur les ajacciens soient
des lieux
chère à leur coeur soit sur des
personnalités
voilà de la ville des clubs de sport ou
alors des personnages historiques
si vous tombez sur la fève gagnante
c'est à dire la couronne de lauriers de
l'empereur bonaparte
vous revenez avec votre faivre qu'il y
aura un tirage au sort le 31 donc
janvier et le lot donc soit la bague en
or rose avec un saphir violet sera
remise par joséphine en personne
c'est le moment de la rubrique
écorégions dans ce gîte et des
territoires
bonjour michel picot vous allez nous
proposer le scan de deux start-up
française qui pourrait bien changer la
vie de personnes malvoyantes ou
malentendantes
quand la technologie vient en appui de
nos vies n'est ce pas bonjour cyril
bonjour à toutes et à tous je sais que
vous aimez les start up et leurs
innovations et bien en voici deux la
première que je souhaitais vous
présenter est à bordeaux elle s'appelle
handsome elle s'adresse aux personnes
mal ou non voyantes en proposant des
solutions de paiement par carte bancaire
sécurisé je m'explique 89% des
déficients visuels ont été victimes
d'une fraude ou arnaque lors d'un
paiement avec leur carte bancaire chez
un commerçant parce qu'il n'était pas
possible pour eux de lire le montant et
la validation de la transaction sur le
terminal de paiement
les commerçants si peu scrupuleux
laurent dit désolé votre paiement n'est
pas passée il faut recommencer la
personne malvoyante recommence donc
l'opération et elle a donc été débité
deux fois d'où l'idée de cette start up
de créer une carte bancaire communicante
avec son téléphone mobile
cette dernière envoie un message aux
téléphones mobiles de la personne mal
voyante qui lui dira au ralliement le
paiement était bien réaliser un
opérateur de cartes bancaires devraient
proposer ce service en 2001 terme autre
start-up rogers voice qui s'adresse
cette fois ci aux personnes sourdes ou
malentendantes qui ne peuvent donc pas
téléphoner ils ont inventé une solution
qui avec de l'intelligence artificielle
permet de mettre à l'écrit les réponses
de votre correspondant il suffit de
regarder son écran pour téléphoner
dans certains cas l'intervention humaine
est aussi possible grâce au langage des
signes
quand la technologie peut améliorer la
vie de tout le monde sans exception il
faut le faire
oui d'autant qu'il s'agit de start up et
non pas de grandes banques pour le
premier cas ou d'opérateurs
téléphoniques pour le second cas ils
sont là nos héros celles et ceux qui
seront changer le quotidien de tous dès
aujourd'hui merci michel picaud et
rendez vous bien sûr dans la prochaine
édition du grand jt des territoires pour
une nouvelle rubrique écorégions tout à
fait autre chose maintenant nous nous
rendons en bretagne où tvr est allé à la
rencontre de chèvre qui sont d'abord des
animaux adorables et qui nous aide aussi
à recycler nos sapins de noël
étonnant vous allez le voir avec ce
reportage de faustine luneau sur place
au contraire de la plupart de ses
congénères
ce sapin de noël ne finira pas
entièrement broyer mais plutôt manger et
recyclés devant le portail de la ferme
trotteurs de coeur mélanie guérin et ses
enfants se charge de le récupérer pour
le plus grand bonheur de leurs onze
chèvres qui s'apprête à goûter à ces
épines
on s'est plaint de plein de vitamines et
oligoéléments et plein de vitamine c
même pour nous un pour nous c'est bon
aussi mais il faut que ça soit donnée
raisonnablement alain ils ont tous mangé
il n'y a plus rien du tout la famille
guérin avait entamé cette démarche
l'année dernière avec les sapins de son
entourage cette fois ci mélanie a vu un
peu plus grand en lançant un appel sur
les réseaux sociaux depuis la fin des
fêtes de noël
elle a déjà récupéré une quinzaine de
sapins les chèvres elles elles mangent
pas du tout le tronc et les branches
donc un paysagiste qui vient et qui
broie ce qui reste moi je et après lui
censé rempaillage les chanceux qui
viennent déposer leurs sapins au bon
moment peuvent même talent et l'offrir
eux-mêmes aux chèvres que mélanie a
baptisé de petits nous affectueux alors
ça c'est biquettes et caramel une façon
pour la jeune femme de familiariser ses
animaux avec de potentiels visiteurs car
elle ne possède pas que des chèvres et
projette de transformer sa ferme en
ferme pédagogique
voilà et puis les chèvres en bretagne ne
sont pas un exemple unique
regardez ces images qui nous ont été
envoyées par nos partenaires
de lmtv sartre ou les chèvres sarthoise
ne sont pas du tout en reste elle aussi
elle nous aide à devenir plus éco
compatibles ceux qui pensent que nous
avons 30 millions d'amis sur la terre on
vraiment raison et puisque nous parlons
de nos amis les bêtes voici maintenant
un reportage superbe qui nous permet un
peu d'évasion il est tourné par les
équipes de vosges télévision
oui ce n'est pas le grand nord mais les
vosges enneigé que nous visitons
maintenant avec nos amis les chiens de
traîneaux vraiment fun et très
spectaculaire ce reportage
regardez jacques c'est devenu moins un
jour en regardant un film de nicolas
vanier donc il ya 15 ans la semaine
d'après on a acheté notre premier chef
les pays bas après là c'était parti et
il en a désormais 26 dont sur ces images
jazz vicky charlie snow ou encore hindi
des chiens petit retour en arrière
plutôt pressé d'aller s'oxygéner
ce sont de ce qu'on appelle de l'alaska
new skies donc c'est des chiens qui ont
été croisées donc à l'origine à partir
du husky pour améliorer ses performances
et ses deux chiens qui ont été faits par
un poids la compétition besoin de courir
ils ont besoin de s'éclater dans la
neige
ils ont besoin et il aime ça donc
ce serait même malheureux de ne pas les
faire courir les chiens qui sont
parfaitement entraînés bien on va dire
nourri correctement on est capable de
faire vraiment les meilleurs attelages
mondiaux font 250 km par 24 heures donc
c'est quand même quelque chose d'énorme
car à 33 ans musher dont ce n'est pas
l'activité principale et les brasseurs
se rend régulièrement en norvège et
c'est pour financer tout ou partie de
ses activités qu'ils proposent sur terre
ou sur neige ici à la chaume du grand
ventron des baptêmes
on demande une demande folle et on
n'arrive pas à répondre à la demande
complètement parce qu'il ya trop de
demandes mais mais c'est sympa rien que
le budget annuel des croquettes est
plutôt conséquent près de 15000 euros il
en faut donc des baptêmes pour des
clients en mal de sensations mais jamais
avares de questions
antoine comment ça se détermine à la
plage cher de tête
alors là les chaînes de tête on est on
est choisi pas vraiment ce sont des
chiens qui sont qui sont vraiment un
petit peu à part c'est vraiment les
chiens les plus intelligents les plus
obéissants font tous partie de notre
famille voilà nous on a 26 xiam c'est ce
sont nos enfants
alors pour une balade en famille à la
chaume du grand ventron compter en
moyenne une soixantaine d'euros
balade voudrait bien terminée alors à la
prochaine
[Musique]
et puis pour les plus frileux d'entre
nous ceux qui ont eu une sensation de
froid après ces belles images des veaux
enneigées voici comment se réchauffer
grâce à laure g lors j'ai c'est une
boisson qui a remplacé le café après la
guerre en france depuis elle est
totalement retombée dans l'oubli les en
côtes d'armor un couple a décidé de la
faire revivre
reportage dans leur atelier de
torréfaction de mathilde de quemener de
tébéo la chaîne du groupe le télégramme
regardez ce reportage quand on en parle
qu'on est des anciens qui voient ça dure
mais moi dans le temps janvier ou alors
des souvenirs dans des pensions ou autre
donc ça c'est intéressant donc en france
avait été un petit peu oublié parce que
c'est vraiment une boisson de guerre et
d'après guerre
l'orge est encore utilisée dans le monde
plein pays en côtes d'armor un couple a
décidé de remettre au goût du jour le
café d'orge alléchés par l'odeur de la
torréfaction certains passants
s'arrêtent dans cet atelier à plaques
l'ermitage par rapport au café j'ai
trouvé que c'était une bonne alternative
à l'or il ya ont d'ailleurs on recherche
derrière le goût du café mais je pense
qu'il connaît et il faut y voilà il faut
effacer de sa tête le goût du café et
mais c'est très agréable
la curiosité et puis surtout de voir
initiée locales et en plus en écoutant
comment ces faits d'où ça vient c'est
vraiment très local l'orge est produit
en bretagne en agriculture biologique et
htl malterie implantée elle aussi sur la
commune de plug davantage une véritable
alternative locale au petit noir il
était restaurateur déjà
dans la baie de saint brieuc avec cette
philosophie là
la recherche du plus court des plus
simples et plus efficaces
et c'est dans un livre de cuisine
gauloise que j'ai trouvé une recette de
café d'or le couple propose aussi une
infusion gourmande au sarrasin ainsi que
des graines de tournesol des graines de
lupin toujours en circuit court pour
offrir une alternative bretonne à ces
produits
comme je vous le disais dans les titres
nous partons maintenant dans le nord sur
le tournage très spectaculaire de la
nouvelle mini-série germinal qui se
tourne dans les hauts de france est en
pleine crise sanitaire quand même
après lille et tourcoing l'équipe du
film a installé ses caméras dans
l'ancienne fosse d'arenberg près de
valenciennes
trente ans après le film de claude berri
dans lequel joue et gérard depardieu et
renault c'est une nouvelle adaptation
une nouvelle superproduction avec deux
mille quatre cents figurants et plus de
700 costumes alexandre roux et olivier
free furent de jouer au télé la chaîne
de la voix du nord sont allés visiter le
set de cette super production télé
regarder des mineurs pioche et lanterne
à la main
le visage marqué en marche vers une
journée de travail la pose d'un robert
fermé depuis 1989 semble reprendre vie
germinal la série est en plein tournage
dans les locaux de creative mine une
production à grande échelle qui
rassemble notamment deux mille quatre
cents figurants tous venus de la région
mon grand-père me parle tellement de la
mine quand ils travaillaient tous tout
ce qu'ils ont vécu que je veux dire
c'est un truc à vivre pour pouvoir au
moins essayer de vivre parce que c'est
pas vraiment ce qu'ils ont vécu mais je
veux dire au moins voir ce qu'ils ont
vécu un budget exceptionnel et mises en
oeuvre
cinq cent mille euros rien que pour les
costumes un million trois cent mille
euros juste pour les décors limites
elles mêmes ont été reconstituées après
un mois de travail
tout le challenge était qu'on puisse
taper réellement dans les murs
de cette vanne vont reconstituer et le
polystyrène posait des problèmes donc on
a pu venir du charbon de bois d'amont
qu'on puisse recréer des parois en vrai
le musée de lewarde nous ça nous a donné
toutes les archives ça va scanner un bon
nombre d'archivés et puis ensuite on a
recherché ne fait pas une documentaliste
aussi pour les puits pour les ascenseurs
pour cela le plus réaliste possible
germinal c'est une oeuvre littéraire
écrite par emile zola mais aussi un film
sorti en 1993 et primée aux césar son
réalisateur claude berri c'était déjà
appuyé sur les locaux de creative mines
enclenchant même la transformation du
site
un héritage lourd à porter il a fallu
nous qu'on se réapproprie lui aussi pour
le
le ramener à ce que notre histoire à
nous forcément on a on part d'une même
base mais on est malgré tout dans une
intention de mise en scène qui est
forcément différente
je pense qu'on a une facilité aussi
c'est que le lieu a évolué depuis 30 ans
mais pas rester tel qu'il est et je
pense qu'il y avait entre temps il a été
aussi grandement refait l'équipe de
germinal passe tous les mois de janvier
aremberg le tournage complet prend fin
dans cette semaine une plongée dans le
patrimoine du nord qui donnera six
épisodes de 52 minutes pour une
diffusion sur france 2 à l'automne
prochain
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
du grand jt des territoires en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale sur vos chaînes de la tnt et
sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve bien sûr très vite pour
une prochaine édition
bon courage à tous au revoir
[Musique]